Ah ! Moi, l'école, ça fait un moment que c'est terminé.
Ça fait partie de l'histoire anci...
Oh non, pas lui.
N, non, non, non, non, ne fais pas ça, ne fais pas ça, NE FAIS PAS ÇA !
L'élève qui a rien.
Je peux te prendre une feuille, s'il te plaît ?
Juste un stylo bleu. Merci.
Je prends juste un stylo rouge, cette, bah attends.
En fait, faudrait que je prenne ta rè...
Attends, bah, tu sais c'est quoi le mieux ?
C'est qu'en fait, d'ailleurs... Hop.
Voilà.
Est-ce-que je peux juste...
FALLAIT AVOIR TES AFFAIRES, PUTAIN !
L'élève qui aime pas la triche.
Et l'élève qui travaille pour les services secrets.
L'élève voleur de blague.
Mon intégrale, elle est douce, parce que l'épilation intégrale.
(rigole) Eh ! Mon intégrale, elle est douce, parce que l'épilation intégrale !
(les élèves rigolent)
(le prof mort de rire)
Ah, Jimmy ! Je te mets 20/20 !
Cyprien, zéro, parce que tu rigoles pas.
J'suis un génie ou pas, hein ?
L'élève surdoué, mais pas pour les cours.
Que tu coupes aux extrémités,
la pression effectuée, que tu peux mesurer en pascals, en hectopascal,
le projectile humidifié au bout va pouvoir...
Juste, je m'en bat les couilles, juste pour l'exercice 2, si t'as pas la réponse...
Je sais pas lire.
Donc, effectivement, une fois que t'as fait la pression...
L'élève tout le temps en t-shirt.
Putain, il fait beau aujourd'hui, hein.
Bon, à tout à l'heure. En physique.
Oh l'enfoiré...
L'élève qui est jamais au courant.
Quoi ? Y a un contrôle, j'étais pas au courant, j'ai pas révisé l'Anglais, putain...
Non, mais on est en histoire, là. Enfin, on est pas en Anglais.
En histoire ?!
On est en histoire-géo.
Putain, on est en histoire, j'étais pas au courant.
Vous êtes le professeur, monsieur Guédon, vous êtes le prof, en fait.
Ok, tout le monde sort une feuille, s'il vous plaît, exercice au tableau.
L'élève qui a trop redoublé.
Tu sais, hier soir, c'est le conseil de classe.
Je crois que je vais encore redoubler.
Oh dit pas ça.
C'est toi qui a écrit ça ?
Déjà, il y a une faute à chaque mot, là.
Le prof victime.
Nous allons commencer notre introduction sur les sciences...
Julien, arrête ça tout de suite, hein.
Monsieur, Julien il est pas là, là.
Ah oui, au temps pour moi, désolé.
Reprenons. Donc, les sciences sociales, effectivement,
ALLEZ !!
Donc, euh, importantes...
Le prof qui sait tout.
L'économiste Adam Smith, n'est ce pas ?
Avec sa théorie de...
Jimmy, arrête de tirer la manche d'Adele avec la trousse dans la main.
Putain, mais comment il fait ?
Le prof qui a perdu les devoirs, mais qui veut pas le dire.
Ce devoir, d'il y a, d'il y a trois mois...
C'est... plutôt pas... C'est bi... je crois que...
Oui, tout le monde a eu vingt. Tout le monde a vraiment eu vingt.
Mais j'ai pas rendu ma copie.
Ferme ta gueule.
Vraiment, on peut même s'applaudir, je pense. Bravo. Bravo. APPLAUDIS.
On en reparle plus jamais.
Le prof qui pue de la gueule.
C'est très bien ton devoir, Jimmy.
Je voulais t'en parler parce que y a quelques petites imperfections, c'est pas mal.
Dans l'idée, tu me feras plaisir quand même dans les sciences économiques,
il y a un besoin de précision.
Il est important, s'il te plaît, que tu reformules la question, n'est ce pas?
Plus vers le haut, vas-y. Merci.
Ainsi que ton développement.
*crache* Merci.
Le prof pervers.
Donc si tu pouvais répondre...
Ah, excuse-moi, j'ai fait tomber le stylo.
Vas-y, ramasse. Un peu. Oui.
Le... Attention. Ah hop. Faut être plus ferme sur le stylo, c'est important.
Excuse-moi. Hop. Un, deux... Ramasse-le. Ouais !
Ramasse-le. Ramasse. Vas-y, ramasse. Ramasse. Ramasse.
Bravo.  (applaudissement)
Oui. Deuxième question, tu peux revenir, en faite.
J'ai toujours rêvé en histoire.
Le roi Clovis 1er, né en 460...
Monsieur, excusez-moi, est-ce-que je peux poser une question, s'il vous plaît ?
Bien sûr.
Qui s'en bat totalement les couilles, ici ?
Ah m'en bats les couilles total, en fait hein moi...
(les élèves sortent)
J'ai toujours rêvé en SVT.
Pour la reproduction sexuelle, on a vu la théorie.
Maintenant, la pratique, Cyprien,
tu montes au tableau, tu choisis une des plus belles filles de la classe, et tu nous montres.
J'ai toujours rêvé en EPS.
Bon, les élèves, on va commencer par trois tours de terrain, c'est parti !
Bah, faites le d'abord pour nous montrer, non ?
Oui, oui je, bah oui, je vais le faire. De toute façon il y a pas de...
OH PUTAIN, LA CRAMPE ! Oh putain !
J'ai toujours rêvé en chimie.
Félicitations, nous venons de concevoir de l'eau de chaux.
Maintenant, on va fabriquer une bombe !
OUAIS !
BBBBBOOOOOUUUUMMMM !
OUAIS ! OUAIS ! OUAIS !
YES !
J'ai toujours rêvé en math.
Les propriétés de l'intégrale sont vraiment très, très, très importantes.
Bonjour, je suis un homme lambda, cadre en entreprise,
c'était juste pour vous dire que tout ce que vous apprenez en mathématiques,
après la classe de quatrième, vous servira jamais à rien.
Du coup, du coup, on peut y aller, en fait ?
Bien sûr.
(les élèves sortent)
Désolé, hein.
Il a raison. En même temps, il a raison.
J'ai toujours rêvé en musique.
Vous voyez cette flûte ? (crak)
On s'en bat les couilles. Allez tous prendre une guitare électrique dans la caisse.
OUAIIIIIS !!
J'ai toujours rêvé en français.
Et c'est par cette allitération, et cette ponctuation,
de cette phrase que nous étudions maintenant depuis deux heures,
que Gustave Flaubert a voulu dénoncer la pression, hein,
subie par notre héroïne...
Bonjour, je suis Gustave Flaubert.
Alors, vous dites que de la merde. J'ai jamais voulu dire ça. Vraiment jamais.
Juste, ça, ça sonnait bien. En plus, mon livre, il est super chiant.
Lisez plutôt Divergente, voilà. Bonne journée.
Ex.. Ex... E.. Exactement.
Pfff... Ah j'ai trop le seum hein. Je comprends rien à l'exercice.